let's go now to Nancy Cordes she's on
Capitol Hill keeping track of why some
Republicans oppose this Senate bill
Nancy good morning good morning there
are a variety of major changes that they
want and those concerns are going to
have to be addressed because there are
now at least 12 Republican senators who
say that they cannot support this bill
in its current form you have some for
example like Ohio's Rob Portman and West
Virginia's Shelley Moore Capito who say
the bill needs to do a lot more to
combat the opioid epidemic and then
there are several conservatives who say
that this bill needs to eliminate more
of Obamacare's insurance regulations in
order to bring down premiums and then
you have means Susan Collins and
Alaska's Lisa Murkowski who want funding
for Planned Parenthood restored on top
of all that they and a number of GOP
moderates say that the cuts to Medicaid
in this bill are just too deep Gale and
are going to leave too many vulnerable
Americans in the lurch Nancy I remember
when it was just three senators opposed
now it's up to 12 so what if Senate
leaders now need to do to get everybody
on board well they say that they're
going to spend the next couple of days
working to cobble together some changes
some kind of compromise that everyone
can live with they're hoping that they
can do that by Friday but then even if
they do achieve that they're going to
have to rewrite the bill and have it re
analyzed by the Congressional Budget
Office which is something Hale that they
were hoping to avoid because it could
take several weeks I know they wanted to
get this vote done before the July 4th
recess Nancy so are they likely to face
angry constituents back home absolutely
you have a lot of protest groups that
have been planning for this recess and
will be demonstrating outside town halls
but the reality is that these senators
were already getting an earful they were
getting phone calls they were getting
emails and that is part of the reason
that you saw so many of these GOP
senators come out in opposition to their
own party's bill and say let's slow down
let's go
back to the drawing board we have
concerns but we think that they can be
addressed so the bill is on life support
but certainly not dead